we do have a lot of real estate in this
first hour but it's currently about to
be occupied by our friend from NFL Films
and one of the top evaluators for an NFL
Draft and we're thrilled to have him
here on the show once again post draft
we had him on pre-draft Greg Cosell how
are you Greg rich what's going on my
friend this story of the draft is what
oh boy I mean a couple things stood out
to me
I thought the Denver Broncos draft
really stood out because I think that
they took the approach that if you're in
the same division with the Kansas City
Chiefs you're not going to win with
defense even though Vic's angio is the
coach you're gonna have to win by
outscoring them and you're gonna have to
try to match their speed that really
stood out to me okay what about the non
drafting of wide receivers by the Green
Bay Packers what do you think there's
what about their strategy in their draft
Greg my sense is and again I'm just
giving you my my feeling about Madeleine
floor knowing his background that he
comes kind of from a Kyle Shanahan
background spent a lot of time with Kyle
I think the feeling is that he wants to
sort of transform that offense into an
offense that starts with a run game and
works off of that which it's interesting
that we live in a time where people
don't talk about the run game at all and
in fact view the drafting of running
backs is if you've committed some kind
of sin but I think he wants to take that
approach run the football work off that
have a rhythmic passing game and not
that receivers aren't important but that
you can run that kind of offense in his
mind without having three or four really
good receivers they obviously have one
really good one in Davante Adams and
they have a tight end who I think they
really like in in chase Stern Berger who
was a rookie a year ago but I think that
that's the approach that madolora wants
to take I guess and then then let me
take the sink because the same approach
we're talking about with Bella check
about why in the world would they just
go into the season with Brian Hoyer and
with Jared Stidham and I'm in sitting
here saying don't sleep on Stidham in
terms of what he can do in terms in
terms of how Bella checks
awaiting him in terms of how he's looked
in practice so you know I mean obviously
we all know the last time we assumed
somebody going in a year to because of
you know of a quarterback situation what
that guy turned into I'm not saying
Stidham is gonna have a Brady like
career but the whole point you know and
I I do want to get to that very subject
later on but what about the receivers
the Packers currently have is are we
missing anything on that front where
they could sit here and say that there's
a second year or a third year jump that
they're planning on getting having on
these guys or that they think so and
that's why they did not rest receivers
you know the way the draft works and
it's funny and obviously we live in a
time where there's no other sports right
now so the draft which is big to begin
with took even it took even more
significance because there's nothing
else going on and with social media and
and everybody now being a draft expert
is the assumption is that when you draft
a player for the most part that you're
filling a need and it doesn't always
work that way you know not all players
make it even first-round picks we know
that so they maybe they feel good about
their receivers I'm not defending mantle
or floor I'm just trying to understand
what he what his mindset is and we're
not going to know that until we play
football you know if you if you last
year said about the San Francisco 49ers
that they would get to the Superbowl and
I see most 'red would be their leading
rusher for the season people would
probably have laughed don't you think
I'm laughing right now I think Jose this
year notion of putting me in that
position you're not wrong
I mean look no so I you know again I'm
not smarter than anybody else right side
you know it's not that's not the point
but I tend to think try to think
reasonably about this and not just have
reactions where oh that's terrible or
that's great or oh that's a bad pick
yeah I like for these things to play out
of it the one thing you know from doing
this and I know who's the people who do
this for a living work a lot of hours
doing this are they always right of
course not none of us are always right
but at least these people work at it
pretty hard there's a reasons and I try
to think in terms of the reasons as
opposed to just having a gut reaction
that it's great or bad Greg Cosell here
on the Rich Eisen show what'd you think
of the Jordan Love picked then
well I have a pretty strong feeling
about that okay and it's probably not
one that a lot of people will share but
I think it also relates to Mattala floor
and his background he wants a timing
rhythm pass game say what you want about
Aaron Rodgers he's super talented
we know that he'll be a hall-of-famer
but Aaron Rodgers over the last number
of years has evolved or one could say
devolved into a player that plays a lot
outside of structure and outside of
rhythm and when you get a chance to
watch the coaching tape as I do and this
is not an interpretation this is what
the tape tells you he leaves a lot of
throws on the field within the timing of
the offense that are there to be thrown
and I guarantee that that bothers Matt
Lafleur and given the age of Rodgers and
who knows how long riders can play the
age of Rogers and in Manilla floor
clearly coming off last season having
probably pretty much carte blanche at
this point I think he's looking to say
hey I'm gonna start to put this offense
together the way I wanted to look and
while Rodgers is great I'm a little
frustrated with the way our offense
plays out and that's just my personal
opinion again but I feel pretty strongly
about that so okay I'm gonna follow this
strand here you're saying that Leflore
had a year of evaluating Aaron Rodgers
and thus we should view the Jordan Love
pick through that that prism that's what
you're saying I think of it this way two
years ago Garoppolo got hurt in San
Francisco and Nick Mullens came in and
I'm not suggesting Nick moans the Super
Bowl quarterback but he executed the
offense at an NFL level okay obviously
the 49ers didn't win a ton of games they
had other issues two years ago as well
Jimmy Garoppolo this year who by the way
not a lot of people think is a great
quarterback by any means came in and say
what you want that team got to the Super
Bowl
so Jimmy Garoppolo is the quarterback of
a Super Bowl team so I think Matt or
floor comes from that's cool let's get a
quarterback who will be a ball
distributor well execute the offense as
its structured does have secondary
action ability when needed because it is
needed at
in the NFL today for sure which Jordan
love by the way does have and let's get
that kind of quarterback in here in
other words when I work 18 hours a day
and put my offense together I would
really like it executed that way and
while Aaron Rodgers is as good as there
is and making certain kinds of plays he
leaves a lot of throws on the field that
are there to be made and it's very
frustrating for a coach and yet if the
floor is coming from the college
Shanahan system Kyle Shanahan's team is
the one that traded up to go get a
receiver in the first round not a new
quarterback you know and I know that
Garoppolo is it and it's funny because
when they made that trade that's the
receiver I thought they would get they
would go for because Brandon I you look
is a great example of a guy that is a
movement receiver you want to get the
ball to him on the move and that's what
the 49er offense is no team used emotion
as much as the 49ers which of course
allows for free releases by receivers to
get into their routes no team threw the
ball in the middle of the field between
the numbers more than the Niners and
that's what Brandon are you giz so they
saw somebody that they really really
wanted and they went and got them and
it's well of course we'll find out how
it plays out but that style receiver
fits the 49ers offense perfectly now I
can only wonder if Aaron Rodgers is
sitting at home right now on youtube.com
slash Rich Eisen show watching us right
now because you know why wouldn't you
well he probably hates my god no it's
not that he hates your guts but I'd be
sitting there thinking you know I can I
can do this off I can run pretty much
any offense I know what what the forte
is of the offense and what my forte is
but he could still hit Brandon now UConn
on the run as anybody else and he would
prefer it you know he prefer to have
somebody like that as opposed to as he's
turning 36 somebody that that they you
know the coaching staff covets like why
can't they covet somebody that would
help Aaron Rodgers in his final you know
maybe you know extended window of
opportunity in the spot where he's put
his blood sweat and tears for another no
and I understand your point and by the
way I'm sure more people feel that way
than what I said but quite honestly I
think the tape shows this I've been
talking about this with Aaron Rodgers
for a number of years because that's
what the tape shows and again then you
have to get caught up in all
was feeling like you have to qualify it
because clearly Aaron Rodgers from a
talent perspective is maybe as good as
we've ever seen in the game and some of
the plays he makes only Aaron Rodgers
can make tape shows what those well what
are you referring to about the tape that
that plays into all this right now Greg
yeah I mean I think that one of the
things you've always noticed with the
Aaron Rogers and this was true with
McCarthy as well and then McCarthy took
all the abuse for it is that he just
leaves and throws on the field that are
there and that's the way he plays and
then he makes special plays so there's a
balance there and every coach will see
it differently and I think malla floor
is in a position where he probably feels
he has as much control as he'll ever
have because he just got to the NFC
Championship game as a rookie head coach
and he probably feels hey I now have a
chance to sort of turn this dis offense
into what I want it to look like so I
guess let's finish this subject by
saying what you see on film and just by
supposing what what and knowing coaches
as well you do and knowing that the
sport and and inside
film rooms as well as you do Greg Cosell
what do you what do you think the the
timeframe is on all this I mean we're
we're probably a year so you're saying
and you know unless of course they get
to the Superbowl I mean I changes
everything course you know but I think
if they didn't who knows I don't the
thing I don't know is Aaron Rodgers
contract situation
I don't Scott although he's got four
years left on people he's got four years
left for oh so I mean theoretically they
would have to get rid of a man who knows
he I guess it will depend on this year
you know you have a similar situation a
very odd situation in Philadelphia which
is kind of weird too as to what they did
you know it's a little different because
Carson Wentz has not finished the last
three seasons but you know they just
paid carson wentz a lot of money and
when you draft a quarterback in the
second round that's not a throwaway pick
well let's get to that then here on the
Rich Eisen show with you Greg Cosell
that's right in your own back here
they're at NFL Films is what the
Philadelphia Eagles were doing we had
Howie Roseman on yesterday said he
wouldn't give me the answers to the test
when I asked him if there would be some
sort of Taysom Hill type package role
for Jalen Hertz well Carson Wentz is
clearly a starting quarterback there
which he flat-out reiterated but he is
when you think there's not going to be
even if there was a true offseason there
would not be a quarterback competition
this year but when you draft a player in
the second round a quarterback and
that's what Jalen Hurd says he's a
quarterback
you're not drafting him to be in a
Taysom Hill role in the second round now
he may end up being in that role now but
you that's the second round pick that's
the 53rd pick in the draft
you know we know whence has not finished
the last three seasons and I love when
says Talent I think when's which still
has a chance to be one of the top two or
three or four quarterbacks in this
league and there are times he plays that
way but you know they know they brought
in Marty morning wink he's on their
offensive coaching staff I believe he
was in Baltimore at the time they
drafted a Lamar Jackson so it just makes
you think I don't have the answer I
don't have the answers to the test
either by the way rigs but when you
draft a quarterback at 53 and you have a
starting quarterback it it's somewhat
similar to the Packers Jordan love was a
first-round pick and I believe they
traded up for him today not Jordan love
that's the point to Greg they traded up
is going to be when they can't just sit
back that's the whole point that can't
sit back and say like Ted Thompson at
least was able to I got Favre coming on
in the third hour hey Brent you know
we're just sitting there at 24 and Aaron
Rodgers fell to us and he could have
been first overall what do you want us
to do you know I'm saying like they went
and got Jordan love and they got him a
spot after the spot the Niners jumped
into to get the receiver I'm sure Aaron
Rodgers was eyeing if he was I everybody
you know sure you know exactly what I'm
talking about I know I'm a little older
than you but I know you're you're a
historian of all sports it's the old
branch rickey you remember branch rickey
of course
yeah it's the old branch rookie
you get rid of players too soon not too
late and you know the fact is Aaron
Rodgers is 36 and he did not have his
best year didn't have a bad year but he
did not have his best year this this
particular season and my guess is that
Matt Lafleur really like Jordan Love on
tape clearly he did by what he did you
know we kind of know that he told you
that by what he did and he's probably
thinking that instead of playing this
out you know Bill Walsh did the same
thing with Joe Montana and Steve Young
now I'm not sitting here telling you
Jordan love is Steve Young we don't know
that but you know I think that that's
probably the mindset that goes into this
you don't want to get stuck going too
far along you know look at Pittsburgh
right now look at Ben Roethlisberger
he's 38 I believe something right around
there coming off a major major injury
and with no real offseason now and they
they don't really know is he gonna play
16 games can he play 16 games we don't
know that
Greg Cosell NFL Films senior producer
and also an analyst for fantasy points
comm which is a brand new fantasy
content site which we'll get to in a
second right here on the Rich Eisen show
Greg you know we're fortunate here at
this program to have talked to a ton of
expert analysts and heard a ton of
expert analysis and I would absolutely
group you in that you clearly led the
league in the most lukewarm
recommendation for two or Tongo viola by
far by far and when it all came down to
it the Dolphins looked at it and I'm
sure they were smoke screening like
crazy or were attempting to trade up for
borough and clearly was not able to do
it stood pat didn't make a trade and got
two after all what do you think about
that pick Greg well it's funny rich that
you say that and and you know and when
you do as much a radio and podcast as I
do as I always try to be careful with
how I see things and it's funny you use
the word lukewarm yes I like to attack a
viola but I think he's a certain kind of
quarterback and there's nothing wrong
with
yeah I've made the point numerous times
that almost all quarterbacks our system
quarterbacks that's not a negative
pejorative term there is very few
quarterbacks who are scheme transcendent
one could easily make the argument and
it's true that drew brees is a system
quarterback and he's going to be a
first-ballot hall-of-famer as he should
be so it's not that I'm Luke warm on two
I did not see him as transcendent I saw
him as a very efficient system
quarterback and if he's used that way
which is the way I believe he should be
used with other factors such as a run
game the RPO game quality receivers then
I believe he can be very very effective
I just did not view his talent as
transcendent why do honestly you're one
of the only few to do that that's why I
used lukewarm by the way in terms of
that I because I know the kid you didn't
kill the kid and you don't do that sort
of stuff you just get your evaluation
and what I just said is not killing to
uh I think I'm kind of talking from a
football perspective I did not view him
as having the same level of talent as
Joe burrow overall I think both of them
have don't have particularly great arms
you know to was not a power thrower I
think too is a rhythm thrower I think
he's very accurate in the short
intermediate pass game I think he's a
when the timing is there and he hits
that back foot and the ball comes out
he's really really good and that that's
the way coaches coach anyway no no coach
says hey rolls the ball out and say
let's run around and make plays today
that's the way the game is coached I
think he's very rhythmic and I think
that you know he's got a few issues that
need to be cleaned up he has a strong
tendency to climb the pocket when
there's no pressure and he moves himself
into pressure he creates his own
pressure and I'm curious to see how that
plays out in the league because he's six
feet tall so there are some things he
needs to clean up but I think he'll be a
very efficient player in the right
circumstance and clearly the Dolphins my
guess is they'll put him in the right
circumstance and he'll probably be
playing sooner than later
Gregg Cosell here on the Rich Eisen show
I've got Kliff Kingsbury join
me later in the show what'd you think of
the Cardinals draft starting with Isaiah
Simmons on down Josh Jones lucky foe to
Rashard Lawrence out of LSU a
fourth-round selection evan weaver and
then ino benjamin from right around
their backyard in arizona's - i think
you have to tie in their draft with the
DeAndre Hopkins as well because that was
a big time move and now they have a
pretty interesting receiving core Isaiah
Simmons to me is his freakish he's one
of those guys I don't believe they'll be
an Isaiah Simmons who comes along every
year when there's a guy who's almost 6
for 238 pounds and moves like that I'll
be very curious to see how he's deployed
I see him as a safety in a base defense
and then of course when you get to your
sub packages he can line up in multiple
positions depending on what you're doing
that given week against the opponent but
I think he's a player who's a space
player despite his size he's not truly a
physical player but he's a freakish
freakish athlete I think you want to get
him away from the bodies not where the
bodies are so that's why I believe he's
more of a safety type in a base defense
his size says linebacker but his style
of play says safety elana I mean I guess
what Tyrann Mathieu is somebody that
people are sound like a bigger Tyrann
Mathieu who has been behind what he is
or ad Erwin James type and Durling James
is probably more physical but he's
really kind of a big freakish Tiran
Matthew in terms of getting ready for
the season it's pieces of a puzzle it's
free agency it's draft it's also who you
might be able to acquire right around
the new league year and DeAndre Hopkins
with lyre Fitzgerald and and Christian
Kirk and Mickey and you know obviously
that that's when you know the move that
they made last year also for Kenyan
Drake him signing his tender of course
he's gonna want to stay there have no
question about that
man to be able to go ahead and and turn
that into the 2020 season with Kyler
Murray in this mix off of the Offensive
Rookie of the Year with Kingsbury this
is very exciting in the desert certainly
with Simmons if you think he would be on
the level in between Chandler Jones and
in front of Patrick Peterson that is
some serious noise maybe the most
overlooked great pass rusher in the
league simply because he plays for
Arizona and no one ever talks about
Arizona but his sack totals over the
last four five years are off the charts
he is a great great pass rusher he sure
is and that division tie means much no
wonder the 49ers want to go out and get
Trent Williams what would you make of
that move how significant is that move a
really significant because I think with
that offense number one it starts with a
run game and then in pass protection
you're dealing with a quarterback in
Jimmy Garoppolo it was very very
rhythmic and he no longer he stays in
the pocket in my view anyway based on
tape the less effective he is he is
truly a rhythm player so pass protection
is absolutely critical and even though
he's not a statue he's not really mobile
in a strict sense it's not going to make
a lot of plays outside of the structure
of the offense so I thought that that
was a really really good move so you
have to count that as well as part of
what they did in the draft because now
they have a starting caliber left tackle
who's coming in to replace a guy who's
maybe well be a hall-of-famer in Joe
Staley and they don't miss a beat on the
left side because trend Williams at his
best is atop what two or three left
tackle early oh gosh that's why I said
John Lynch you know the 49ers said the
best draft the best draft to me is you
know when you or you could say the best
draft the day after the draft with some
level of certainty when players are
selected that are widely viewed as
significantly talented and to take a
second first-round selection that you
get because you're flipping a player as
talented as Buckner to a team that
that's right there in the middle of the
first round and you can then turn that
pick into a younger cheaper or less
expensive let's use that phrase version
of him while also paying somebody else
on a defensive line that also includes D
Ford who's your second round selection
from this year so you could kind of slot
D Ford in there if you want
along with Nick
from last year I mean I could go on and
on as I did yesterday and then you draft
someone like I uke with the fourth round
selection you get to move out of that
first round spot just one spot so
another team can select the offensive
lineman that they wanted and if you
could sit there and go man you could
have taken that offensive lineman with
Staley retiring no no you're gonna flip
that fourth round or later on to the
first four for the wide receiver and
then get Trent Williams later on I mean
that the other thing he considered to be
quality players there's a certain group
of those guys and then there's a lot of
guys who are in the I are evaluated you
know by people like me or you know and
some of us sometimes we're right
sometimes were wrong
you know Daniel Jeremiah who's great at
this yes um you know there's and now we
have a ton of internet people who do
this and they start you know ripping
pics or loving pigs and it's it's simply
based on their view of the player and
that's okay that's the fun of it
but yeah I like to take the approach
that these teams do a lot of work and
they have a pretty good sense of who
they're drafting and why they're
drafting and of course they don't all
work out but you know I'd like to think
they know what they're doing a few more
minutes left with you Greg Cosell let's
go back to let's take the pin out of the
Patriots quarterback conversation so now
now through all this eat
belcheck said afterwards it wasn't by
design not taking a quarterback and now
it's cinemates Hoyer and the only other
options would be a veteran should Andy
Dalton pop free which we're assuming
might happen because burrow was there
clearly there's Cam Newton out there who
would be what would say the the
glitziest most expensive potentially we
were expecting to have Jameis son with
the Saints so we could take him out of
that mix it sure looks like Stidham
don't you think yeah I do
and I think you'll see them kind of be a
run first team and a defense based team
and a special teams based team and you
know I think Belichick go work through
that you know they they'll run the ball
they they lost James Devlin but they
signed an vitaly a fall back so he'll
fill that role they'll they'll use
Sonne Michelle again they still have
Damien Harris who is a third-round pick
last year out of Alabama
I think they'll try to work the run game
and have a pass game that is is highly
structured and is you know takes some
shots here and there but they're not
going to be built on the pass game and
unless again we don't know what's going
to happen in the next couple of months
but if it stands the way it is now I
would expect that Stidham will line up
and be their quarterback yeah it sure
looks like that way and what do you what
do you make of the Jamis going to New
Orleans Greg do you like it if he if he
goes to the Saints you mean yes sir yeah
I think it's a really good spot for him
because you know I think at this point
he needs probably to rehabilitate
himself a little bit he's certainly a
talented guy but I think the issues that
he's had with turnovers have been
problematic and I think to be in the
quarterback room and learn from Brees
and who knows how long drew plays but I
think it's a good move for Jameis not
only to be with Brees but to be with
Sean Payton and to learn up you know a
really strong system that really defines
things well through the use of personnel
and the use of formations and you know
the great thing about a guy like Brees
is as much as he's throwing the ball
over the years with very few exceptions
he doesn't throw a lot of interceptions
so you know I think it's a really good
spot for Jameis to rehabilitate because
he's a talented kid I think he'll end up
being a starter in this league again at
some point okay before I ask you one
last draft question and send you off
into this good Tuesday what is fantasy
points comm Greg what are you involved
with on this front oh it's a great site
with John Hansen John Hansen who's
probably I think he was the first guy to
start fantasy well over 20 years ago and
I've known John for Oh probably 15 plus
years I've worked with him for quite a
while and he just started this new site
and you know he wants wanted me to be a
part of it as far as you know providing
the X and O information and that's
basically what I'm going to do is I'm
the X and ho guy okay you know I'm not
I'm not a fantasy guy in the strict
sense that I've got three teams and you
know I see how they do every week but I
probably providing the xno information
and I'm really excited about it it's a
phenomenal site it's it just came up I
think last week
and already it's doing really well so
there's a I have a ton of draft
evaluations and I'm gonna continue doing
those and put those out and they'll go
on non fantasy points comc points comm
again all right so is there one pick or
one aspect of the draft I didn't ask you
about that you want that you want to I
guess throw a spotlight on you thought
it was a great value pick to use the
phrase anything that you want to throw
out there well I play the Cowboys are
going to be really interesting on
offense because they really have a ton
of weapons and you know they scored
obviously they gained a lot of yards
last year and scored a lot of points and
didn't make the playoffs so it'll be
really interesting to see their offense
because CD lamb he had about over forty
percent of his catches this year at
Oklahoma came from the slot and I
actually think the best place for him to
start his career is in the slot I did
not see the DeAndre Hopkins comparison
that a lot of people threw out but I
think lamb is a good prospect and I
think within the context of that offense
with Cooper and gallop and gallops the
overlooked guy leaned over a thousand
yards receiving last year I think the
Cowboys have a really really intriguing
offense and then I what does it Swain
was the tight end there now - well no
it's Blake Charlie I think they refined
and he's actually very very athletic
nice so they've got athletes all
throughout you know they still got
Elliott you know we don't have time now
but this whole running game thing is I
find fascinating the way people just
dismiss the running game and running
back because if it they don't even exist
well we'll hit that later later date
appreciate the time Greg thanks very
much rich really appreciate it thanks
for having me of course at Gregg Cosell
on Twitter and check him out again on
fantasy points dot-com senior producer
of NFL Films Greg Cosell he's seen a ton
of tape his stuff on matchup his stuff
as you can hear is we could literally
spend all three hours with him out
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here